is there a go live oh it's already
recording we might already be live is
that right
yeah it's a recording it's not go live
it's just recording so people can read
okay
later oh but even we're not live yet
no we are not live yet yeah this is live
this is live people can join in now yeah
joining here oh it is live okay okay
yeah
all right um hi everyone we'll we'll get
started in just a minute uh
tim do you do you have i think you sent
the slides over
to to share to somebody right you want
us to put them on
this will also give everybody a minute
to join which i think is fine
did we lose you tim
oh here we go you came back
tim can you hear me
i can hear you yeah
oh tim can you you can hear me yeah i
can hear you
all right i think we are live now so but
i was having
some connection issues
yeah your voice is still breaking up i'm
not sure if it's because you're outside
or
i'm getting an echo of a when when
tim speaks all right let's let's wait
for him if not we will have tim come
back later in uh
and he can talk about the community
weird
it's really weird tim maybe get off the
video and uh
oh this is it seems better now i'm not
sure maybe you get off the video and
just do audio
and i see people are joining that's
awesome hello everyone we'll get started
in just a minute
all right i'm gonna share real quick
that's not probably what i wanted to
share patrick what do you see do you see
my terminal or do you see
accelerate your career in data science
machine learning ai
perfect that's tim's slide so tim if
you're here if you came back
this is your chance
if you're just joining us welcome we'll
just get started i'm
waiting for tim to come and tell us
about this amazing community they have
and also there's some free resources
that you'll all have access to
which is pretty cool
all right he's back let me add him back
as a host
okay can you hear me i can hear you can
you see the slide 10
i can so yeah i'll go for it hi everyone
my name is tim boniman i work on the ibm
data science community
here out of the beautiful bay area and
uh just wanted to share this offer
if you join the community you get one
month's worth of complimentary access
to select ibm courses um
they're pretty good we get good feedback
um so definitely check it out
and on the community we have about 14
000 uh data scientists uh
uh ml engineers and others uh you know
sharing their their work their projects
their insights
so definitely worth a look and uh hope
to see you there and enjoy the meeting
meet up
wonderful thank you tim uh patrick uh
i'm going to stop sharing and i'll let
you
bring the slides up if you don't mind it
sounds good give me just one second here
i need to make sure
my okay vpn is still connected
i'm going to start sharing my screen
and then all right
presentation mode uh we're good to go
we're good to go perfect
um so again uh let me give you one
second
all right so welcome again everybody
sorry for for
a little bit of a late start here we had
some connection issues
uh but hopefully the course the free
course in the data science community
that
tim showed you uh hopefully makes out
for those glitches
my name is opkar i'm a developer
advocate at ibm and i'm joined today by
my colleague patrick hey patrick
hello um and we are here today to
talk to you about a lyra to introduce
you to lyra so
i see um you know i see some attendees
who are
look um watching us live if you can uh
let us know in the chat have you heard
of alyra before
do you know in a what the
open storage solution that we'll talk
about today have you heard of that
before
first time okay felix first time for you
okay anybody else i'm just curious to
see
tonya says maybe yes okay
anybody else and also i have another
question actually um
if uh if you could let us know once i
think first time
nope okay all right well a lot of
newcomers this is perfect patrick
um my second question is i know this is
uh
you know this is a data um centric
uh data science centric meetup but i'm
just wondering how many
uh folks in the audience are data
scientists versus
interested in data but do something else
for a full-time job
um if you can let us know in the in the
chat that'll also help us out during the
talk and and
doing the demo we can cater a little bit
to the audience
data scientist ashish thank you
very cool so look a lot of a lot of deep
data science experience that's that's
that's really good to see
um this tool this tool will be
uh i think you'll find it useful um
so again uh i've introduced myself
uh patrick if you oh there's there's
some more introduction on my part i
forgot forgot about this
so i am part of the ibm developer team
um
primarily work on this hackathon called
call for code it's our
annual hackathon we had we just
announced winners for last year so if
you're interested
in building solutions for to help
communities in need
uh it's it's it's sort of a code for
good kind of hackathon
the interesting part is you know you if
you win
you get two hundred thousand dollars in
uh cash price but also
you get help from ibm from the linux
foundation
and other open source uh companies to
help you actually
stand up your solutions on the ground
right so you get a lot of help uh
and collaboration that way as well um so
if you're interested
uh google call for code ibm it'll take
you to that site uh we just
uh we just launched another one um
it's called embrace and i'll let you
read more about that on
on the website itself because i know we
you know we're here for another topic
today
apart from that i am also author a
couple of courses on coursera
so i know tim gave you a list on his
site but
if you're interested uh if you're
interested in you know containers
kubernetes openshift
that side of things which i think is
becoming more and more relevant for
for data science and and patrick will go
you know into into the details a little
bit more later um so let's see daniel is
very interested in call for code amazing
okay cool i'll uh
i'll also paste the link in the in the
chat
for you all right with that patrick i'll
hand it over to you for a brief
introduction
all right thank you so first of all uh
thank you everybody for for joining us
today and of course for
for inviting us uh my name is sir
patrick titzler
i'm a developer advocate with the center
for open source
data analytic technologies
our team is based in primarily in the
san francisco bay area
but we have about 40 plus developers and
data scientists
that are working alongside us
on various open source projects and what
you can see here
on the right hand side is just a small
selection
of some of those projects that
we're actively contributing to and i
should probably say
so those 40 developers most of them are
contributing
almost full time to projects but as you
can imagine
being part of ibm and open source being
so important for
for all of us we have several thousand
developers globally who are actively
contributing to open source software not
just
in the general area of ai but
across the entire open source software
stack
that you might be using on a day-to-day
basis
in uh the session today that that
upgrade and i are going going to lead
we are going to focus on one very
specific project
project called lyra which is part
of the python data science stack and
this is what you can see
on the top of this little chart
surrounded by a little box just to
highlight it
what we are going to do is give you a
brief motivation
while we created the lyra project we're
going to
show you a demo of the highlights
of uh elira and then we're just going to
open it up for some q a at the end
uh i'm going to give you a live demo and
while
i go through with the demo i will not be
watching this the chat so what we're
going to do is
uh upgrade any time uh we'll
be able to just interject so if you have
a question that you would like to get
answered
either he can answer that question in
the chat or
if it sounds like a question that would
warrant a
longer personal answer then uh he can
just uh bring it up as
as i move along and then we'll discuss
the answer here on the air last thing i
wanted to
say about these projects that you are
seeing here these open source projects
some of them like the ai fairness the
ai explainability a project or
the art project where um created by ibm
research
so those are some of the open source
projects that we are contributing to
but you can also see a bunch of very
familiar open source projects like
tensorflow like apache spark
like pandas or scikit-learn
so we as a team of developers and data
scientists
are actively contributing contributing
to a lot of those
open source projects that are relevant
in the general area
of artificial intelligence so with that
um webcast going to go through a brief
motivation
all right thank you patrick so you know
when we asked a question
earlier uh i see there are a couple of
very experienced and professional data
science
data scientists in the group here so i
mean you know this this picture should
not come as a surprise to anybody here
um although i did ask a question i asked
if you use jupiter notebooks at jupiter
labs in your daily work so i
there's one answer saying no i'm here to
learn that's wonderful you're
most welcome um and we'll do our best to
to show you the solution today and
hopefully it'll be useful to you
for for the data scientists in the in
the room
uh do you uh do you use jupiter
notebooks
um or do you use jupiter lab have you
worked with jupiter lab before
generally not thus far but starting to
do so for certain classes
okay very cool um that's that's good to
hear
uh yes of course of course uh prosper
um so if the answer is yes of course um
i'm curious also to know what are some
of your
pain points in jupiter notebooks uh they
are wonderful
for for a lot of use cases right so
for me personally uh they are wonderful
to experiment
they're wonderful to break things and
and quickly fix them
uh and fail and then succeed and you
know it's
every cell it's it's easier
for me to work around the cells working
by myself than
a big dot py file or python file where
you know um i have to jump back and
forth so it's
and the second thing it's a really
amazing education tool right so when i'm
doing webinars or i'm working at
mentoring at hackathons i find them very
very useful to
to explain something to somebody because
each cell kind of
you know it um it depicts a step in my
in my algorithm or in my modeling and
i'm able to say okay here's
we we acquired the data using
you know normally in our case it might
come from a cloud object store it might
come from a csv file sitting on github
if i'm using penis to do some data
massaging or whatever
um so you know acquiring data analyzing
data
uh processing data that's i have
different cells for those it's easy for
me to show
and then i have one cell just for
training of that data using something
like psyche learn perhaps
and then i deploy the data or sorry i
deploy the model
to something like uh watson machine
learning are
available on ibm cloud um so if
again if you're new to data science
these are sort of the the
typical data science life cycle right so
you uh they say
uh 90 or 80 of the of data scientists
work is actually working on
on data and cleaning the data because
trust me like in real world
like kaggle is not real world well some
competitions are real world but for most
part for in kaggle that
they clean up the data before you get it
right i worked at um
at school districts across the united
states and we used to work with student
data their historical great data
and other uh other kinds of data right
also some private data like health data
and things like that
and it was it was so hard to to get all
of the schools to talk the same language
when it came to data and tables and
what kind of databases to use uh they
were all over the place so i
i agree uh with that sentiment
completely
so acquiring data then once you have the
data a lot of times the data is you're
brand new to the data so you take some
time to get used to the data
uh you need a certain level of intimacy
before you go get into
close to any sort of modeling right
because that the kind of data would
influence what kind of models you pick
and sometimes um so once you have
analyzed the data you may start to
process the data which could mean
cleaning the data up removing certain
kinds of noise from the data
looking at outline outliers and how the
outliers will affect your modeling
and then you start you start working
with models and
you never just you know pick one model
and go for it right the the general
tendency is to have a couple of models
compete against each other and you pick
the best model given
based on certain evaluation criteria
which again depends on the problem
depends on the kind of data
but let's say you've done all of that
you have you've optimized your
parameters
you have done some feature engineering
to find new features that work
better with the data that you have um
and then at that point you're ready to
you're ready with your model
you have a really good um you know rc
curve or you may have a really good
error rate or some or you know whatever
whatever cost function you're trying to
minimize
and that at that point you have your
model you want to deploy it
you again like i said you can you want
to deploy it at scale
so you go to something like watson
machine learning on ibm cloud
and you can deploy that model and then
you that's not the end of the story then
you start monitoring that model you
start monitoring that model for
performance
um and also you start um
you start looking or monitoring that
model for bias right for bias detection
which which is a whole different webinar
on on bias and explainability
that we have done in the past as well uh
that being said
i'm looking at some of the answers here
and andre is saying revision control is
the biggest name
i completely completely completely get
that um
uh have you tried differing to ipy
nb files it's it's it's a pain i used
you know i used to work on
apple uh mobile apps and they use xcode
and i forget what it generated i think
it generated xml it was really hard to
compare again
um let's see
daniel great notebooks are great for
prototyping out prototyping algorithms
and documenting data analysis role
but difficult to develop or debug any
reasonably large body of code using
notebooks
perfect that you're leading me on to my
next slide that's that's awesome right
so
those are exactly the pain points i
experienced as well um
when i was reusing notebooks there was
no way to use mvc for
visualization based apps ha
mvc is that like model view controller
for
creating web applications and then do
some sort of visualization that's an
interesting thought daniel
yes yeah that's an interesting thought
okay so
you know as the picture says a picture
says a thousand words although i've
probably said more than a thousand words
um you can see the top one is
is our typical notebook where you have a
bunch of cells it's monolith it's doing
many things in the same notebook
and at the bottom is what you know
software engineering
good practices tell you to do they tell
you to break your code into modular
pieces that talk to each other
it was a really good line i i read in a
book it said
monoliths are strongly coupled and then
microservices or modular code
is loosely coupled but strongly aligned
right so they are all working towards
that same goal of making a really good
software
but they are not they might be dependent
on each other but they're not
um they're still in the modular in in
in that sense um so that brings in
patrick if you can move to the next
slide
and we'll we'll show what people have
already said here right so this says
unless patrick shared the slides
beforehand you kind of read our minds
right these are common problems so
how do i reuse uh code in jupyter
notebooks
if i if i have a team working on a
single notebook now
in i know in watson studio which is our
our
machine learning product there's way too
ways to collaborate but still it's hard
it's hard to share notebooks and share
sales insight notebooks how do you do
that source control or version control
like daniel was saying it's it's uh it's
a pain right now
uh the other thing is running remotely
right so i'm on my mac
and i'm working on this notebook and i'm
working with a bigger data set
and it's taking up a lot of resources
how do i um
how do i take that work and offload it
to another
server or something on the cloud right
so the jupyter notebook if the if the
notebook is running
on the cloud that's a different story
right if you're using cool app or if
you're using ibm watson
that's a different story but how do i
run individual pieces of code
or certain pieces of code um remotely
and the other one is like how do i run
bat jobs right so that's where
uh maybe once a day or something your
your model goes off picks up data
and then you know runs the prediction
gives you back
a result in a csv file how do i do that
how do i schedule
uh bad jobs right that's another problem
with jupiter notebooks
and then the last thing is ml workflow
so again as daniel was
was hinting to you know it's good to
experiment uh it's good for prototyping
algorithms and models but then now you
have this
cell after shell after shell and off of
code
um what does that workflow look like
right so let's say i want to now
get get a new data set in but i don't
want to change
or i want to change like somewhere some
things in the middle of the notebook
without touching the top part how do i
do that another thing that those books i
which i always
always get into trouble with is the
order of the cells doesn't matter right
so if you run
something at the bottom of the notebook
it's whatever variables are stored in
memory and then you go to the top and
everything still works fine
and a lot of times i tend to run them in
a random order and either it's not going
to work
or i tend to overwrite my variables from
previous cells so in either case i can
do trouble
apart from that like the whole workflow
so we talked about getting the data
processing the data uh doing feature
engineering
uh there is a way to do a data pipeline
andre
um so i realized that is that are you
referring to
like for example scikit-learn has this
whole concept of data pipeline
where your uh you're you're sort of
plumbing
different parts together to create your
ml pipeline
so yes i i get that but you're still
doing everything inside
a single notebook right so uh with that
being said uh
yeah yeah exactly under yeah so so i
realized that there's that way to do it
uh but you'll see that you'll see how
that changes
with elira and it's a different way of
thinking thinking about the whole
pipeline
so patrick with that i'll pass it back
to you right thank you
so uh what we're going to do in the
remaining
like half hour to 35 minutes that that
we have left here
is just give you an idea how
some of the features that elira provides
can help you um solve some of those
those issues right that you you're
dealing with on a daily basis and then
sometimes
the thing is if you have to do the same
thing over and over again
uh little problems that you run into or
little usability issues can can get very
quickly very annoying
right and so what we have done is
uh we've done some analysis we looked at
so what are some of the typical tasks
that you as a data scientist would
perform on a day-to-day basis
and then we've tried to come up with
some solutions right how can we extend
in jupiter lab in such a way so that we
do have the ability to reuse code right
and for that we're introducing
the code snippet editor which allows you
to do exactly what the name implies
right you define
um a piece of code that you register
some place
and then you can insert this code you
can insert that code for example into a
notebook
if that code happens to be a markdown
you can insert it into a code
into another notebook cell that is
tagged as being a markdown cell you
could insert
code into java if if this
is what you do
more frequently with respect to source
control
you'll be extremely happy to hear that
with lyra and jupiter lab you now have
git integration so if for example if if
upgrade if you're working on the same
project
we can now share our notebooks and our
other artifacts
within jupiter lab by exploiting the git
integration
extension that we're going to show you
if you have for example a training job
that you have built which could be for
example a python script
we have the ability to run this on a
remote machine right i mean
probably the way you do this today is if
you have access to
another server for example that has more
powerful hardware resources
um that you can utilize um ussh into
that machine
uh and then you run the script there
right but as you can imagine
as you know this is not very efficient
right and
with elira we give you the ability to
run the script from within
your jupiter lab environment on that
machine
and then access the results that this
script is producing
within your jupiter lab environment with
respect to
uh having the ability to run a note
notebook as a badge right
was uh mentioning this earlier
if let's say you have a notebook that
comprises of
many cells of course yes you do have the
ability to run
all the cells right but still you have
to open the notebook and then you have
to
click that button to run through all the
cells
we do have a feature here that in lyra
that allows you to take a notebook and
then submit it for execution
in a remote environment so for example
if you have access to
a particular server that has the
resources that you need
to run this notebook in an acceptable
amount of time
you can just submit it and then we'll
run on that machine and you have access
to those
results again within your jupyter lab
environment and last but not least
implementation of ml workflows
we have implemented a pipeline editor
which gives you the
ability to chain notebooks or python
scripts together
so that you can automate certain tasks
that you're performing on a daily basis
so that for example if you need to load
data and cleanse it
you don't have to run each one of the
notebooks individually
but you can create a pipeline that
combines those two notebooks and then
when you run the pipeline
you get the output from both of those
notebooks
after that pipeline has executed
so for those of you on the call who are
not familiar with jupyter lab
when i go through the demo i'm going to
give you just a very quick um
quick overview but before i do that i
want to say a few words about
how you would go about implementing a
machine learning workflow
using pipelines so let's assume
you did what was mentioning earlier on
right where he said
it is a good practice to create modular
notebooks right so
notebooks that tend to do just a few
things
but not everything so that you can reuse
them in other projects right and one
example that i like that i like to give
and you can also see this here
in this little workflow diagram that i
have
let's say you have a set of notebooks
that process some data that analyze the
data
might perform other operations over the
data
now um that data might reside in a
database it might reside on cloud
storage
it might be in a github repository um
ideally
your notebooks shouldn't need to know
right where that data is living
and if you have credit for example
python script or another notebook
that just takes care of the data loading
right then you can abstract the fact
where that data resides
uh from all the other notebooks right
and you suddenly start
to have this set of
notebooks and scripts that you can reuse
over and over right in different
projects
a pipeline is nothing else but a
combination
of python scripts and and stupid
notebooks as you can see here
um the scope of such a pipeline it's
completely up to you
right so whether you're trying to build
a pipeline that does
every single task of typical data
science workflow
you can do that if you just want to
combine a set of sub-tests you can do
this as well
right so for example if you just want to
load and pre-process data in the
pipeline
you just combine those two in a pi
in a pipeline that you create and you
run this pipeline and you get the
results right if you want to do more you
just keep adding more nodes
to your pipeline so before i actually
show you uh how you would go about
creating a pipeline
i i did want to spend a couple of
minutes
just introducing you to cube flow in
case uh you have never heard about it
so uh what i've pasted here on top so
it's the formal definition right so if
you look at the documentation
for um q flow it says okay it's a
scalable reportable distributed machine
platform that runs on kubernetes
but what does that really mean so think
about
um a very simple scenario where you are
a single
let's say data scientist and you're
working on a project
on your own right so you start looking
at the data you start
analyzing it probably looking at fairly
small amounts of data
so you're going to use your nuclear lab
environment right and mostly you're
going to
use your notebooks to perform
those steps you might then go through
the exercise of building a model of
training a mode and figuring out okay
which one of the models that i have
created is performing the best and then
you decide okay
uh i have a model that meets my
prerequisites
or it meets my stated goals and i can
now start
to serve this model right by for example
implementing a little web app that
surfaces
um some functionality that
is utilizing the model that you have
created now this is all good and fine
if you are a single data scientist or a
small group
but when you think about the problems
that arise from an operational point of
view
if you're trying to do this at a scale
right what if
there are hundreds of users who are
working with notebooks
what if your models require gigabytes or
terabytes of data
right you're not going to run any of
this on your local machine anymore
right you will would want to take
advantage of hardware resources that
that are available to you either in a
data center that you have access to so
it could be a set of servers so for
example
if you are a student at the university
if you are
a research assistant you might have a
bunch of
servers available in one of your labs
that you can use
right if you are in a startup company
right you might be leveraging cloud
resources
that google amazon
ibm or microsoft provides
or if you're an enterprise you might
have access to combination
of those services right so you might
have a bunch of servers running in your
local
data center and you also might have some
resources
that cloud providers are making
available to you right
and with um hubflow uh
you can scale your operations right so
because cube4
is implemented on top of kubernetes
and kubernetes is uh pretty much
supported everywhere right so whether
you have a
server that you're running in your data
center all of the major cloud providers
are supporting it
so you have now achieved portability
so that you can perform any of the steps
in your workflow in any of those
environments without really having to
change anything
right and as you get involved or if you
are already involved
in a lot of large-scale projects you
very quickly see
that operations is becoming a major
effort for everybody involved and just
making sure that everybody has access to
the resources that they need
for example um when you run a training
job
that you get the resources you need so
that this training job completes in a
timely manner
and when you maintain the models
that you make sure that at all times
you're not just wiping out an existing
model
but you have the ability to switch
between
different versions as needed so that you
can find out okay is the new model
version
that i have now deployed is it
performing better as i perform
for performing worse than a version that
i might have previously deployed
in my environment now q4 pipelines
is one of the components in
kubeflow and its main purpose is it
serves as a platform for building
a deployable portable and scalable
machine learning workflows
and what i'm showing you here in this
squad graph
is just an abstract workflow that you
have to complete
if you want to uh create and run a
pipeline in a qr pipeline's environment
first step is you use the python dsl
and dsl stands for domain specific
language to define the pipeline
artifacts so what are the components
that make up
the pipeline that you want to run once
you have defined that
you compile this into a workflow
specification
which is something that kubeflow
pipelines understands and knows how to
process
then you upload that that specification
to qfloors pipeline and then you can run
that pipeline
in the environment where it will then be
processed using all of the resources
that are available
in that kubernetes deployment on which
uh q4 pipelines
is running so how's this different
if you're building pipelines with allyra
so in the previous slide i was showing
you okay there are several steps that
you need to go through and some coding
in order to assemble those pipelines
with elira we are providing you with a
visual pipeline editor
that allows you to assemble those
pipelines
just using a graphical user interface
and we under the covers or live under
the covers
takes care of generating all of the
artifacts that are required
to run those notebooks or python scripts
in
the targeted environment right so we
make it a lot easier for you to just
take whatever you already have
and then run it uh in an environment
like
um like tuples pipelines
uh one important thing that i do want to
mention
um because i do realize um
in a development environment right so
let's say um
you're just starting off where you are
trying to build your model
uh it does make perfect sense um to run
a pipeline locally in jupiter lab
and within elira we give you that option
that that opportunity
so there are certain use case scenarios
uh where you can run can run those
pipelines
in that environment but then there are
other scenarios
where you would really want to run those
pipelines in the cloud or
on on a different machine
that has more resources available to you
so this is where i'm going to switch um
to
the demo uh before i actually do this
i'm just going to open up for any
questions supka that
people might have asked that are worth
going through
um yeah for sure there's a question on
cube flow so the question was
um have the has the q flow team develop
the event triggers um to make the
pipeline
flowing uh you know one container needs
to
signal to notify the other status to
start running
and andre is saying a few months ago
kubeflow didn't have this functionality
is is that something that's uh um
that's implemented on the kubeflow side
so i don't know if uh
if this is event specific but in general
yes
if you have to find a flow
where you say that one part of the flow
is
dependent on the other it will only kick
off
the let's say the second component after
the first one has successfully completed
so in that respect um it already does
what you're looking for um but you you
might be specifically interested in
a slightly different feature i guess
where you want to dynamically
um somehow trigger execution of of
something else
that isn't necessarily part of part of
the flow
if that is the case uh maybe this is a
discussion that um that we can have
offline perfect perfect and then i know
you went through the pipeline stuff
um sherry is asking like can you can you
define the pipeline here again like
conceptually what does that mean and i
know you'll give some examples so maybe
we can uh
we can show it right i'll do this in the
demo
uh which in fact the demo itself
um i'm going to show you several things
i'm going to show you how do you create
a pipeline using the visual
pipeline editor in elira uh how do you
run the pipeline in jupyter lab and how
do you run it in kubeflow pipelines
the demo that i'm showing you here while
i'm switching
screens is based on a bunch of tutorials
that that we have published
so um let me just make sure
in the right location here okay so i'm
just going to start my jupiter lab in my
local environment here
and should come up in my browser
okay and this um should look familiar to
you
um let me actually switch to i don't
know
let me actually stay here so um
what you see on uh the right hand side
is the launcher
that you're probably familiar with
giving you access to common features
like
how do i create a notebook how do i how
do i access
the console how do i do other things but
one thing you notice
uh in this installation of from
supertelap that i'm running here on my
machine
which is the development build of of
jupiter lab and
ndlyra i have no access to additional
tasks right so i can see
i can now invoke the pipeline editor i
can create a python
file or i can access the documentation
so
let me start off by simply importing
the project that i have stored in github
so in order to do that i just open up
the get entry here
clone repository i need to specify
a url so i'm going to do that by simply
copying and pasting something
in here so in the background
jupiter lab is now cloning that
repository
into my workspace and you can see here i
have already a bunch of files in there
so let me drill down into one of the
directories here
and open one of the notebooks
so now this view here is very familiar
to you
right it's the classic notebook
interface where you can see
the cells the documentation that you
have you can step through the cells
but the reason why i'm opening this up
is to show you some of the features some
of the
productivity enhancements that we have
put in as part of the allyra extension
so let's say for example um i'm making
a change to this notebook right so let's
say
for whatever reason i'm
adding a cell here and then i'm going to
also run it and run a couple more cells
here so that i can produce
some some output
so if i now switch to
the github
view here you can see that um
jupyter lab now and that alerts me to
the fact that
i have a notebook here that has been
modified right and if i'm curious okay
what are the changes that i have applied
i simply right click on that
on that notebook um
actually it should have i don't know i
forgot sorry
i need to save my changes and now in the
background
jupiter lab is comparing the changes
that i have made
with the original notebook and if i now
look at the difference
between those two versions we can now
see
that uh-huh indeed i did add
a cell i have some more output and if i
scroll further down here
i can see that in this one cell that i
ran
i can see now that output right so i
don't have to leave my jupiter lab
environment anymore
um to figure out okay what are the
changes that i have made
one thing that i really like about this
github feature and
i only accidentally stumbled across it
um a little while ago
um you do have the ability to of course
stage those changes and then commit them
back into the repositories i'm not going
to join
not going to show you that but you also
have the ability to discard changes
which can be extremely useful useful so
let's say for example
um you're running a notebook all the
output
cells are now populated and you just
want to get back to
its original state right if you just
discard those changes here
it will do that for you right without
you ever having to leave
youtube with a lab environment now
let's say um you are working with a
notebook
that um is a lot longer than this one
let's say it's a monologue
monolithic a notebook that spans uh
20 30 whatever number of pages right one
typical problem
that you probably have is
it's extremely hard to find things
in your notebook right and this is where
the table of content feature
is probably going to help you a lot
because what happens
is if you switch to the table of content
view here
or if you open that that panel um
we automatically generate that table of
content for you right and if you click
on one of the the section headings here
we actually jump to that appropriate
place
in your notebook right then you can see
if you have a longer notebook
this makes it extremely easy to just get
to the place where you want to be
now this capability of the of generating
this
um this this table of content for
notebooks
is not unique i mean it's also available
for
markdown files it's also also available
for python script
that's right so the same kind of concept
applies there
so uh another typical problem and then
we've discussed this when we went
through the pain points
is let's say you have some common code
that you frequently use
right so let's say for example you have
a certain type of visualization that you
really like
if you're working on notebook and you
need to
put this code in i mean what you do
today
most likely you're trying to find
another notebook where you've already
implemented that code and then you're
going to copy and paste it now the
problem there of course is
if you have dozens or hundreds of
notebooks well
where's that notebook right we have it
readily accessible or not
um if you if you define code snippets um
you won't have to deal with that anymore
uh very simple to create a
code snippet you just give it a name i'm
just going to give it a
a triple name here you choose the
language
in which the code snippet is defined so
in this case i'm just going to
define markdown code snippet
i save it it now shows up in my palette
here
and now if i want to use this code
snippet and actually i'm going to use
one of the predefined code snippets that
i have already in my
in my workspace here um i can simply
insert
this into my cell and i'm good to go
right
so uh this uh over time you will see
um it can be an extreme time saver
right because now uh you do have this
reusability aspect of code um
that you didn't really have out of the
box with
previous patrick it it really reminds me
of
uh github gists and i'm wondering if
there is any connection there or if
these can be saved
somewhere like that yeah
so i i at this point
those code snippets are stored as part
of
internal metadata in the local file
system so we currently don't
have the ability to export for example
or share
code snippets um in other environments
but it's definitely a good idea
one thing we are we're looking at is how
can we make it easier
for users to to share those code
snippets right so whether it's through a
gist or whether we have something like
an input and export feature we can
choose which code snippets you want to
export and then some
another user can import those it's still
still a work in progress
[Music]
okay so then uh let me move on
to the pipelines and the main reason i
think why
most of you are here so let me go back
to my
set of notebooks that i have predefined
and let's start building a pipeline
so i've opened the pipeline editor and
now i'm just going to drag and drop
a bunch of scripts and notebooks onto my
canvas here
so in this case i'm going to build a
fairly simple
pipeline
where you place those um
those we call them nodes on the canvas
doesn't really matter
because dependencies between those nodes
you define by connecting them
so if you connect the output port of
a node with input port of another node
that implicitly defines the execution
order
right so if we were to run this this
pipeline now
it would first execute this python
script and then followed by this
notebook here but what i wanted to show
you here is
you can also model something like this
right where
if those note if this second notebook
here completes successfully
then both of those other notebooks would
be run in parallel
because the only dependency is on this
first notebook but not on
on each other so this
is how i simply build or
assemble a pipeline good practice of
course is
to document what a particular node is
doing so
i'm just going to put in here load data
net
load data set so that if for example i
save my pipeline
and then share it with opka that he
knows okay what is
what was my intention right what am i
trying to do here with my pipeline so
he doesn't necessarily have to look into
each one of the scripts to figure out
uh what what is the purpose of a
particular node that i have added
to my pipeline now before i can
run a pipeline like this i have to
define its
runtime properties and i have to do this
for every single node so
for python script i have to specify what
is
the runtime environment or docker image
in which i'm going to run this
if i want to run this pipeline in a
remote environment
but i also can define input file
dependencies so let's imagine
um you have a notebook that is using um
some python code right that you have
stored uh not in
in in a in a package
but maybe it's just stored in a python
script you can define this as a
dependency here
and then elira will take care of
packaging everything that you have
identified as a dependency
with this pipeline so that when you run
this in the target environment
everything is available to you if
your script or notebooks have a
dependency on environment variables you
can define those
and in my example here
i do need to define one of those
variables and i have a cheat sheet open
so that i don't have to type everything
in
and this didn't quite work as expected
let me do it again
so i'm just copying the value that i
need to put in here
pasting it and last thing i have to
specify is
what are the output files that the
particular node is producing
you'll see when when we run this in a
queue close environment
why we have to do this in my case here i
just have to specify
a single data file that this node is
downloading from cloud storage for me
to specify this as my output i'm saving
my
my change here and you'll notice that
nodes in my pipeline that haven't been
configured properly
are now tagged right so you see that
little dot here
that's a warning indication if you were
to try to run this flow now you would
fail
right because you haven't defined all of
the runtime properties so i'm going to
do this
just take a second here
so this one is also going to use a
pandas image
it's going to produce a
claims data file based on the input that
it has
received it doesn't have any
dependencies on any input files on any
other input files
and it doesn't have any dependencies on
environment variables so i don't have to
configure this part
and the last two notebooks here in my
flow i just have to configure
that they use
this pandas image the general rule that
you have to follow is
you can use any of the public images
that
are listed by by default but you can
also use your own images
but of course those images have to make
all the prerequisites so for example the
prerequisite packages
that you are using in your notebook they
have to make those available
so that when you actually run this
pipeline that all
uh all its dependencies are met
so let me save this pipeline here and
now we are actually ready
to run it in our local environment now
out of the box
when you deploy a jupiter lab with a
lyra extension you can run all of your
pipelines
in jupiter lab itself right so you just
give it a name
by default it uses the pipeline name you
can see it chooses
the run in place locally runtime
configuration which is there out of the
box
and when you click the ok button let me
just switch to
my console here you can see now that
um we run
each one of the notebooks and you can
see how this slowly how this is slowly
progressing
in uh in a sub shell right within
jupiter
lab now as you can imagine this works
nicely
for like small workloads that you have
but if you have large amounts of data
that you need to process if you have
notebooks that are performing compute
intensive
tensive stars this might take a very
long time right and that's why we
typically don't advise
you doing this in in the local
environment
however if you're just going through
initial development of a pipeline
it's perfectly fine to do what i was
just
doing here now when the job has
completed execution
i'm going to get a notification message
and you can see now the changes
reflected
in my file browser right we can see now
there is a new data directory which
contains some of the data files that
have been downloaded
if i go back up and open one of
the notebooks i can now see that
the output cells have been populated
right i now can look at the
results so for example if i open up
the data analysis notebook we should see
some visualizations
right and so i didn't have to go through
each one of the notebooks and run them
i could just kick off this pipeline and
everything was done for me
so this is how you would run a notebook
locally in your environment now let me
show you
uh how you would do this in uh
in an environment we have access to keep
close group pipelines
deployment i'm just going to invoke the
same
run button here but this time i'm going
to choose a runtime configuration
that i have pre-configured in
preparation for the demo here so i'm not
going to show you how i did this
this runtime configuration basically
just
includes the connectivity information
where my cube flows to pro pipelines
deployment
is is located and it also includes
information
about the cloud object storage instance
that
we are using to store um the data that
this pipeline is producing
now what happens when i submit
i'm so sorry to interrupt you were just
pointing that so i thought this was a
question i can ask now so tony is asking
uh
where is the output data stored in
between the notebook steps and i think
you just showed that to us in the
yes right if if you if you run a
pipeline locally
everything is stored in your local file
system because each one
of the notebooks and each one of the
python scripts that you run
is executed in the same environment
so in essence you are initiate
everything environment
so you have access to it in your file
browser however when you run this
in a kubeflow pipelines environment in
that case
each one of those nodes in your workflow
is executed in isolation
so if my like my my my workflow here
um comprises of four nodes each one of
those nodes is executed as a separate
container
and each one of the containers is
isolated from the others
right so uh whenever when i run my load
data python script
it doesn't have access to any of the
data
or any of the information that's
accessible to this notebook here
right in order to solve this problem we
use
this cloud object storage instance that
we can use
as the medium to exchange information
between those two nodes so when i kick
off a job like i have done
this dialog comes up which gives me two
links
the first link that i just opened um
opens up the kubeflow pipelines
console in which i can see the
execution so this is what you would
typically use for monitoring
you can see that in this case
the first node so the first node in my
flow
has already completed the second one is
currently in progress
if you're interested in what's happening
you can just open up the log file
and then follow along one thing you
notice
is you don't see the complete graph
right you only see
the nodes in the execution graph that
have already executed
that are currently executing so if we
wait um
just a couple more seconds here those
other two nodes
that were dependent on the dependent on
the data cleaning process
should show up and you can see this here
and
again if i switch to that node i can
access the log file
and then monitor the progress of
those operations
now this pipeline that i'm running here
is of course a very simple one right it
just takes
about a minute minute and a half to to
complete but
imagine a scenario where you're working
with a lot of data
right where um you have a data analysis
or
or some some model training where you
want to take advantage of
gpu or tpu resources that you might have
available
in a kubernetes cluster this is really
where you get the performance boost
right that
you would never see if you were to run
this pipeline in your local environment
now when this pipeline execution
completes
um i can access whatever artifacts have
been
generated when that pipeline was um was
executed
and in the current release of elira
you access those ad effect those
artifacts
by um by using
um a browser that gives you access
um to that cloud storage instance so
fortunately for us
out of the box when you deploy um
kubeflow pipeline an instance of min io
is already pre-deployed for you so you
get everything that you need
and if we now look at
the bucket which i have pre-configured
for this particular runtime environment
we can see
that i have a pipeline here
and i actually see this is the untitled
one pipeline that i was just running
we can see if i drill down the data
files
that have been produced when i ran this
and you notice here
it's just two files right it's only
those files
that i have declared as output files so
anything else
that any other files that might have
been produced
while one of the notes was running
wouldn't be available
to you unless you have declared them
if i go back to the root directory if i
download one of
those html files here if i open it up
we can see an html version of the
completed notebook
with all the output pre-populated right
so if
any charts were produced
you can access them here so
if you if you just want to preview what
the results were
you would just access the html files if
you wanted to access
the ipython notebooks with the output
files
you can easily do that by selecting all
of the files for example if you use
minio
and downloading everything as
as an archive
from the cloud storage instance
so before i i i closed my demo here this
is one thing i wanted to call out
um as you can imagine um having to
manually access
those some output artifacts through
an external browser window isn't really
very user friendly right so what we are
looking at and what we are working on
is integrating this more seamlessly into
the jupyter lab environment
so that for example you might be able
to access those ad effects through the
file browser
or uh we might introduce something like
an
and cloud storage browser that gives you
access
to the bucket so that you can very
easily
download those artifacts um into your
your browser and then um into your file
browser and access them there
so with that i think i've covered
everything i wanted to show so okay if
there any
questions that have come up as part of
the demo here
i've i've tried my best to answer a few
of them but there's uh
there's a couple more so um one of them
is um
let me read the latest one so the
question is in your jupiter lab notebook
how do you access the min io data source
so that we showed it in the kubeflow
version of it and i guess they're asking
how to configure that
okay so how do you configure the
notebook uh no no
so um very good question um if i
understand it correctly so let me
um be a little bit more clear in
let me open up this notebook here when
we look at this notebook
um what you see and then hopefully
you can read this and this is not too
well
it's coming here for you okay so maybe
this is a little little better here
and so you can see um this notebook
doesn't really know anything about the
fact that
this data file came from cloud storage
right the notebook itself assumes that
the data file is available locally
and a lyra is taking under the covers
care of making this file available to
the notebook
because what happens is if i go back to
the pipeline here
let's say we're running this first node
here um
the node completes its execution elira
will then automatically
download or upload all of the files that
you have defined as an
as an output as an output file to the
cloud object storage
instance and before the second notebook
key is executed
what elira will do is it will download
the files that are on that cloud storage
instance
back into the local file system right so
that when this container runs
where this notebook is being executed
and the file that i have declared as an
output
is now available to the notebook without
you having to do anything
so in essence you don't have to
customize your notebooks
to actually do this right this is done
for you
and then completely transparently
perfect let's get into the question
i i think so thank you thank you patrick
so very similar to that um and i know we
are a little bit
running over but i think there are lots
of questions so let's
if it's okay with you let's stay uh you
know let's let's see and finish this
so the next question is very related to
this is sherry
sherry asked if everything that goes
into the cloud object store
as output everything has to be
configured unless you
unless you declare them you won't see
them is that correct
yes that is correct um fortunately
you won't have to like in this case i
specified a single file right but what
you can do is
um you can also specify wildcards so for
example if i put this in
data forward slash asterisk
then all of the files in this data
directory would be
would be exported so you don't have to
specify every single one of them
but yes the answer you're absolutely
correct
you need to define it otherwise it will
not be available to you
okay perfect um and then we
have another one here sorry the
questions are all in the chat instead of
the
q a version some i'm filtering through
through
here um
okay luciano kind of answered one of
them the question was how do you tell
which cos to use which cloud object
store is oh okay
is and that's the runtime metadata that
you
you tell it which which because i think
the original question was how does it
know to use min io
yes right let me actually show this i
didn't want to show this part of the
demo but
it's it's fairly fairly easy so um
if you open up this um runtime
visit that lauren introduces um
if you create a new runtime environment
you give it a name this can be some
anything arbitrary
and then you define like what is the
endpoint
where this queue for pipelines instance
can be
can be accessed you specify username and
a password
if that if that instance is protected
and this is where you would specify okay
what is the endpoint for
um the cloud object storage instance
that that you are using
what is the username what is the
password and what is the bucket
in which um those artifacts will be will
be stored
and i had done this in in preparation
for the demo
let me just open this one up you see
here on the left hand side
um when when you define this you get
essentially two links
if you open up the first link it drops
you right into
the qr pipelines console if you open up
that second link then it opens up
a browser window for you not object
storage okay perfect
so you just have to define it once and
then it's available um
for all of the for all of the pipelines
that you have
associated with this runtime environment
and what we tend to do is
we tend to use um several environments
so we have equipped floor environment
for for development we have one for test
so that you can very clearly separate
and the different projects that people
are working on
perfect another question from andre is
it possible to connect a javascript
module to the pipeline
it's javascript at this point the answer
is
no so the the only two types of notes
that
we are supporting right now is this
python scripts and
and python notebooks
um i don't think um
we actually are going to support the
javascript
nodes in the future but but one thing
that i should probably call
out is uh even though everything we
showed today right
was evolving around um q4 pipelines
our intention is to make pipelines
available in other environments as well
so for example if you are
a customer who has or who uses
apache airflow today to run workflows
you will be able to run this pipeline on
in such an environment as well right so
we try to be here agnostic and then so
if the target environment supports
execution for example of javascript code
then um there would be something that we
can do in the future
um to run such code or such a node
in that target environment but for for
the time being in this first release
here
um we're just focusing on two
environments running and running locally
and running in purple pipelines
perfect um there were a couple of
comments on how can i try this can i try
this uh where do i get this code and i
know you're getting into that so
that's the good segue into the next
portion here
yep exactly right uh and we have only
two two more slides here so let me
switch over so how can you try this out
right and then
we have several options for you um not
sure
if if everybody on this on this call is
familiar with binder
um it's uh basically an open source
project
called repo to docker that
gives you the ability to create a docker
image
from a github repository we have
done this and we have published a binder
image
for lyra so when we
share the slides here you have the links
handy so but if you click on this link
here
what happens is it will open up a
sandbox environment
in the cloud that is being hosted for
you
and then you can try these things out
without having to install anything
the disadvantage of course is since this
is hosted in the public cloud
um the resources that you have available
are extremely limited and once you shut
down that image
you lose everything that that you have
done
uh a better approach is therefore if you
want to run
lyra in a docker container the community
publishes a set of those containers
if you look at the tags the latest
public release of a lyric is always
tagged as latest
if you're looking for specific version
you just specify
xyz as as the version so the most
current version that we have
as of today is version one to one or
if you feel really adventurous if you
use the dev tag
then you will have access to docker
container that
contains the most recent development
build
but of course that build might not be
very stable so i personally wouldn't
really recommend
using those containers
for anything else but basic exploration
last option that you have is of course
you can install the lyra on superlab
look locally in your environment um so
if you have node.js and python 3
installed on your machine
[Music]
you can pip install everything
if you're using conda as your package
manager you can
use the condor recipe or if you'd like
you can also install everything
from the source code and the link that i
have here
has all of the details that you need for
each one of those options that we are
providing you with
last thing that we wanted to share here
is
um if what we have presented today to
you
uh seems interesting um
we are more than happy to welcome you to
the lyra community so if you um
open up the link to the github
repository that we are showing here on
top
um you have access to all of the
information that we have shown you today
we have a community meeting every
thursday where we talk about
the latest developments where we have
users ask questions
for give us feedback for example
we also on gither so if you want to get
a hold of us
in between those community meetings you
can easily do that
we've also published um a bunch of
pipelines that you can use to try this
out so what i was showing you
was the tutorial pipeline that walks you
through those through those tasks step
by step
but we also have some more complex
pipelines so
probably our most most repeating example
as of today is the covet 19 pipeline
if you go to this github repository you
get everything that you need you get the
notebooks you get the pipeline
you simply clone the repository
into your workspace into into your
jupyter lab environment
and you're good to go and you just just
follow the instructions there
the two more pipelines that we're
working on an airline delay analysis
pipeline
that is going to go through some more
in-depth analysis
of of of two data sets um that um
that we are processing then it's going
to do some prediction
uh trying to forecast okay um how good
or better going to
our going our airline's going to perform
uh
in the future based on some some weather
patterns and then last but not least
we're also working on a pipeline that
illustrates how you can analyze
um how fair um your your models are
right so if you want to identify okay
it's their bias and the model that i
have created
a pipeline like this can can help you um
find the answer to that question and
last but not least
if you want to reach out to us um we are
on the web on
at cuda.org we are on twitter at
create.org
or if you want to reach out to either or
myself personally
you're more than welcome to either ping
us on twitter send us an email
or reach out through any other means so
that's all i had
garden of uh is anything else that you
wanted to
bring up or if there any more questions
that we can answer
no this is perfect uh this is perfect um
patrick i must i might have missed it
did you talk about bias
at all at the end i just
uh uh so i i brought it up in the
context of this
um this pipeline but if you do want to
say a couple of works uh
a couple of words about it um i didn't
because um it's more of an advanced
topic but definitely a very important
one
got it so so sherry was asking how does
pipeline help
uncover buyers so i think sherry the
idea here is the
the coming soon the ai fairness analysis
that'll have some pipelines
the pipelines themselves don't help
uncover bias pipelines are
you know a way for you to run your your
code as patrick showed today
um no that was great thank you patrick
luciano uh
had a comment here which i want to read
out because it's i think this is the
amazing
awesomeness of open source he says
alaira is open source
so you could create an issue describing
your use case to use javascript
and even come and contribute so as
patrick you were saying welcoming
welcoming people to the the github repo
and the community
at large i think that's a that's a
really good point um so i think andre
was asking about uh
uh javascripts andre uh again this is
this is uh
an invitation for you to come in and
contribute
yeah definitely and then we are um
i mean we we so when we um
when we're looking for contribution
right so we are looking for
general feedback that you have right we
are looking for
um if if something doesn't work for you
right
open open an issue file a bug we're
happy to fix it
if you have an enhancement request like
what you were mentioning okay is that
the ability
to run javascript open an issue will as
a community take a look at it if there's
a viable
approach to doing it we might be able to
um to deliver um if
um you'd like to contribute code that
can actually
support what you're looking for you're
more than welcome to open a pull request
right and then that edition would be
part of the
official code base so there are
different ways that you can
contribute um to lyra or jupiter lab
in general right because i mean at the
end of the day
it's not it's really not about a lyra
it's about
making jupiter lab a better
development environment for every one of
us right who's using it on a day-to-day
basis
so if for example um and this is
something i didn't really get into
um traditionally when you used like um
the jupiter notebook interface
all you could do is really interact with
notebooks right but
with jupiter being an integrated
development environment
you have now a lot more options so let's
say for example
if somebody were to implement a csv
file editor you could now natively open
csv file
in jupyter lab you could browse the
files and
you might be able to automatically
generate some some charts right based on
the data
that's that's stored in there right so
there are many opportunities
where um contributors can now
add functionality to jupiter lab that
traditionally wasn't available to you
in a notebook or was only available to
you if
you actually coded this in the notebook
itself right so
jupyter becomes more of an ecosystem of
of extensions
that just make your life easier in every
single way
um possible in your day-to-day
activities
i i thought i was already a csv uh
editor um because when i i remember when
i started using when i moved from
jupiter notebooks to jupiter lab
like that was the one of the things that
i was i was so happy that there's a way
to see my
my csv files like big csv files right in
jupyter lab
they might have i don't know if they
took it out or if it's still there but
that was one
of the uh you don't have to see us yeah
yeah that was one yeah here so for me it
was out i was
i'm like i'm all in this this is exactly
what i want
all right so maybe this was this was a
bad example but um
just just think about the potential here
right if um
if if you want to do more than this
editor can do at this point
right just exactly just extend this this
extension
and everybody will benefit from it i'll
i'll
i'll get you started on that if
anybody's interested uh when i was
looking at this i didn't find a way to
sort by column
so if somebody wants to implement sort
by column that'll be good
all right cool um so um
there's a comment from sherry on okay so
i
i think pi data meetups is answering
perfect they've answered that question
so i think we're all done here patrick
thank you so much uh
and thank you pi data for having us over
and and talk about it lyra you can see
patrick myself luciano we are very
passionate about this project
uh i think it's an amazing project so
there's there's no reason not to be
uh and if you have any questions patrick
can you put the oh
never mind that's okay i was gonna ask
you to put the last slide up but
let's put in our twitter handles in the
uh
perfect i've put it back up and then
we're going to share the the
presentation with everyone
so that you have the links
awesome thank you everyone we'll see you
next time
all right thanks for having us